mohsin zeddy grew up in a devout muslim
community in a deprived area of east
london
struggling with his sexuality he felt
isolated from his family
but found a love for education he was
the first person from his school to go
to oxford university
he went on to work at the un the uk
supreme court
and today is a criminal barrister in one
of the country's top chambers
often working on high-profile cases he's
also an advocate of lgbt rights and
being representation
and has a new book telling his story a
dutiful boy
a memoir of a gay muslim's journey to
acceptance that is out
in august i'm pleased to say now that we
are joined now
by mohsen himself really good to see you
this morning and handily a copy of the
book just over your right shoulder there
mustn't
tell us just a little bit
tell us just a little bit about about
your story it
it is one of struggle yes it clearly is
one of struggle
but it's also one of achievement
yeah i mean more than struggling
achievement i would say it is a story
about hope
and about love um more than anything
it's
i would say the love letter to my family
um when i was about
14 years old i remember creeping down
the stairs
to watch queer as folk uh
surreptitiously while everybody was
asleep upstairs
and watching it i just had this sense of
unbelonging and something being not
quite right
um and i could see myself on the screen
and that sense of unbelonging kind of
stayed with me as i
went to university and
realized that um not everybody needed a
student loan
um or that i'd never heard of eaton and
harrow for example and
people were surprised i didn't know what
they were and so my response was well
have you heard of walthamstow secondary
school
and when they hadn't i just thought they
were the same um
so then and then that sense of
unbelonging then stayed with me again i
remember last year i was walking into a
courtroom
um into a magistrates court and one of
the court staff mistook me for the
defendant
um so one of the reasons for writing the
book was
i guess to find a space for people like
me
to feel like actually we do belong and
so
that kind of experience i had with queer
as folk where i saw myself
the hope is that the book will do that
for younger people
i i know from from a couple of friends
just how significant
the russell t davis drama was to to them
and and
not just in identifying their own
sexuality but in the process of them
them coming out i wonder how that is
dealt with in the book
given that you grew up in such a devout
religious family
yeah i mean you know i i know the
headlines always talk about the fact
that um
my dad called a witch doctor to the
house but
you know that was people think of that
as a really nasty thing to have done
but it was an act of love perhaps a
misguided act but an act of love and
ultimately
you know my dad is one of my and my mom
are two of my biggest advocates today
and that's something that i'm so
grateful for
and that was the other reason to write
the book was to say that
there is more than one narrative it
doesn't just have to be about
oppression of minorities well they must
certainly have been instrumental in your
your push your your love of education
the drive that took you all the way from
east london
to an oxford college to study law
yeah i mean i'm not sure i would call it
a love of education i don't know how
many people
love education um but yeah i mean
completely you know they they were
immigrants themselves and
they we talk often about um
immigrants unfortunately usually it's in
a negative tone but they have
a really hard work ethic and they knew
that the key the only way that that
their children were going to make out of
the circumstance of you know being in a
council house
was education and so i remember like
when we were kids if we wanted to go and
go to the park my mum and dad would say
you can go to the park but first
you have to do a comprehension exercise
or go do your homework or
read something and i resented it at the
time and unfortunately i think so much
as with so much of life you realize as
you get older how right your parents
were
so it's thanks a lot of this is thanks
to them well i wonder then how you might
have felt if you had been doing ua
levels in
in 2020 i don't know whether you had an
unconditional or not from oxford whether
you needed your grades
but if you needed grades to be booted
out of school for several months and
then ultimately to find your results
downgraded because of the
the school that you went to i wonder
what your view might have been at that
point
you know only it's something like only
2.2 percent of
uh kids from the least uh from from
sorry from the most deprived backgrounds
end up with the a-level grades to go to
the top
universities um you know i'm appalled by
the way
that young people to today have been
treated
uh and unfortunately it has
disproportionately
affected people from more deprived
backgrounds i mean
anecdotally and i'm not sure if this is
true or not but i've heard that eaton
which i do now know
um didn't have any of their grades uh
downgraded and i this is not about
eaten it's just about the fact of um
fairness
and you've got young people who have
worked so hard who do
come from really difficult backgrounds
who have done everything they possibly
can
who are now being told well sorry
because of some formula we've decided
that you're a star
which you would have got yeah um we
don't think he would have got mohsen i'm
i'm so sorry
we do have to leave it there but it is
an inspirational uh story
entitled a dutiful boy as i said just
carefully place
over your shoulder thank you for joining
us